(upbeat music)
(logos pop)
(screen whooshes)
(keyboard clicks)
- I think it's really exciting
how biology and creativity have combined,
particularly in the area
of health and outcomes.
And how do we help people with blindness?
How do we help people who are paraplegic,
where we can start to read
the electrical activity
of their intended movement
and have a robot do that.
So they can gain, you know,
that activity again,
and have that power in their lives again.
I think that is a classic
and beautiful example of the combination
of biology and creativity
making our lives better
every single day
- Butterflies use something
called structural color
which involves bending light
to generate color instead
of using a bunch of pigment.
So it definitely saves the butterflies
a bunch of energy in making that pigment.
But now because of some observant
and innovative scientists
it's saving us energy too.
It's being used in screens
around the world to
make them more efficient
at projecting color, which
reduces the carbon footprint
as some of our most common electronics.
And how about the creativity of using mRNA
which is pretty much just
biological text messages
to give our bodies a heads up
that they need to recognize
dangerous viruses.
It's the technology being used in some
of our most innovative vaccines right now.
(screen whooshes)
(upbeat music)